c'est une toute nouvelle émission que
vient d'annoncer ses huit sur son
antenne à compter du 31 mai prochain
influenceurs au coeur de la french house
ce nouveau format s'intéresse aux coûts
du collectif d'influenceurs le plus
puissant de france sur les réseaux
sociaux la french house synthétique
locker qui a eu tout ce que disent des
millions personnes sur tik tok instagram
ou snap tchad au cours de dix épisodes
diffusés chaque jour à 18h10 sur ces 8
nous allons pouvoir suivre leur
quotidien en colocation dans une
magnifique maison au coeur de paris
franchement les coulisses de la création
de leurs vidéos leurs partenariats avec
des marques prestigieuses mais aussi les
moments plus difficiles face à la
pression mv raphaël sacha marine et
louise
ils ont entre 16 et 22 ans qui sont
encadrés par imhotep plan manager et
créateur du projet âgé tout juste de 19
ans quand c'est une business c'est du
business
le pari à la grèce sans façons par le
sud de la france cette émission va nous
faire plonger dans la vie extraordinaire
de ces cinq jeunes créateurs dont vos
enfants sont les plus fans
[Applaudissements]
qu'est ce que vous pensez de ce nouveau
concept maxime que ces mythes selon
sedan c'est une bonne chose parce qu'ils
ne l'ont jamais fait s'essayer le prix
on n'était pas ce qu'on nous vend pas
des candidats de télé réalité mais
directement des influenceurs on voit
tout de suite la couleur
deux de ces jeunes finalement on suit
des jeunes un peu créatif un peu suivie
et je trouve ça vachement bien que ces
huit tailles sur ce terrain rachel alors
moi ce que je trouve incroyable c'est
que non seulement ces audacieux c'est
novateur mais on ne connaissait même pas
le son de leur voix pour certains et
surtout ce qui est très intéressant
celui qui va falloir suivre ces imhotep
c'est lui qui va crever l'écran vous
allez voir il est jeune il a 19 ans il a
eu cette idée de génie et je pense
qu'ils vont non seulement aller voter
c'est lui qui va falloir un un jeune à
suivre de très très très très près
ludivine bah écoutez moi de base je ne
suis pas la première fan de télé réalité
et mac j'adore qui est ma soeur le sait
c'est on n'a pas ça en commun la tnt
mais je vais tâcher de départ c'est un
petit peu ma même ma curiosité qui n'a
pas forcément envie de m'envoyer sur ce
terrain parce que je pense qu'il ya
évidemment toute affaire et maxime il
l'a dit on c'est la télé réalité ça
plaît aux jeunes c'est 8 c'était s'ils
étaient intéressés grâce à magali
d'ailleurs et au numéro un que j'ai
suivi des influenceurs que j'ai trouvé
très très bien mais je trouve que la
chercher dans la nouvelle génération
parce qu'ils sont vraiment très jeune
c'est pas mal
j'ai envie de voir pourquoi ils ont
accommodé nicolas sarkozy et les voisins
puisque les filles ce qu'ils habitent en
face j'ai envie de voir ça mais bon on
va le voir je crois dans ces images
anissa alors moi je pense que ce
programme va cartonner complet parce
qu'il faut savoir que la communauté tik
tok c'est vraiment assez incroyable il
son pays passe à des 60 millions dé 30
millions fin c'est énorme
donc je pense que les fins et candidats
sont sur tik tok à la base
donc je pense vraiment que ça va être un
problème qui va cartonner que la paire
aux jeunes même si je sais pas si
parfois c'est bon pour eux mais en tout
cas ça va être un cas si ça peut être
que bon pour forcément magali moi je
suis super contente parce que forcément
mardi enfin une chaîne son jeu vous
intéresse influenceurs non mais t'as
bien ce petit nom c'est enfin une chaîne
s'intéresse aux influenceurs moi ça fait
longtemps que je faisais attention les
influenceurs on livre on parle beaucoup
d'eux en mal on les catalogues beaucoup
on les critique on les prend un peu de
haut ils sont un peu sur le côté dans le
milieu médiatique
et pourtant aujourd'hui réunissent plus
d'audience cru beaucoup d'émissions de
télévision dont était temps qu'une
chaîne de télé prennent le risque de les
mettre à l'antenne
et c'est modern et là je suis très fier
je serai puis après c'est pas tout les
influenceurs qui sont bien aussi parce
que y'a bien mauvais exemple dans les
influenceurs aussi l'école oui comme par
le père mais c'est vrai je pense que là
non mais là c'est dans ces mauvais ils
ont fait de bons choix toile assez bon
esprit voilà là c'est bon esprit c'est
bon choix c'est des petits jeunes frais
qu'ils ont un pied en l'air sincère mais
par contre je mets frais fixes mais
qu'est ce que c'est qu'un investisseur
n'est pas bien là ce soir
aussi parce qu'ils sont les seuls stocks
c'est à dire souvent les influenceurs
c'est vraiment très instagram très
snatch atlas et tik tok eux c'est
vraiment des stars sur tik tok et c'est
bien parce que c'est ça montre aussi un
nouveau réseau c'est ce que tu connais à
magali c'est très bien magasiner un
plaisir de vous entendre vous le savez
je vois passer souvent je vous aime dit
donc bernal